il n'avait pas tout à fait le même style
de il est plus j'ai l'impression que le
plus sportif matt non vous êtes beaux et
les plus jeunes nous y voilà et plus
nous et qu'on a on m'a pris pour lui a
pas longtemps
non c'est pas vrai oui merde un voisin
chauffeur on peut dire les marques ou
pas n'ont soit sur lui un chauffeur
labeur pas pourquoi ça choque faire quoi
le beurre açucar qu'hubert humeur
comment vous dit un chauffeur
saint-hubert lui prêt je monte un
chauffeur ont peur c'est un chauffeur au
beurre en fait et regard dans le rétro
il me dit ah je suis trop heureux je
vous adore me suis programme
je lui dis je ne suis pas matt pokora et
il me dit pas si gênant vraiment je vous
promets je suis pas lui et me dit je
comprends très bien que vous vouliez pas
le dire on s'arrête là si vous voulez
pas parler je ne sais vraiment pas ça je
ne suis pas matt pokora et me dit ok il
me fait un petit sourire et il ne
voulait même pas le croire sophie pantel
à clapet 1 c'est super flippant parce
que croire chauffeur qui a deux dixièmes
à chaque oeil non j'avais là-bas tu
parle un peu anglais
ouais d'accord au little c'est ce qu'on
dit souvent quand on voit matthieu
delormeau tenu les cherry on va tout
jouer à c'est les soldes c'est les
soldes chez les chaunois beaucoup de
jetons coustous dit je trouve pas
d'emploi combattre les choses au niveau
là jean michel meyer une boîte de 12
préservatifs phosphorescent quelle
taille c'est pas les prix et à l'éveil
pas quatorze mois plus de 17 mois et 16
c est combien 16,4 à lisbonne
le boulot
[Musique]
je vous l'offre et ses propos récents ça
peut faire un sabre laser dans le noir
bonjour on vous mathieu zafrane opinel
mac tu m'entends mon chéri et maintenant
pas mais c'est pas grave
alors eh ben on y va à l'écran on n'aura
que sont quand même bon ça en est où ce
casting c'est qu'il s'en sort bien sage
et revit salut mon pote
[Musique]
derrière une vitrine je tiens à prendre
ça pour parler c'est mu il paraît que
toutes les galères et une non ça va bon
sang madame aime à trench est les pets
les descentes j'aimerais qu'il nous
fasse une petite chorégraphie sur le
plateau pour nous durant là les doigts
très fort
[Applaudissements]
vous savez non j'avais pas venir c'est
la surprise totale
ouais elle est bonne tama - la l1
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était c'était ça fait cinq ans et
pas partie d'un surpris
[Rires]
[Musique]